I know you mentioned lately that you'd be quite excited...
...to slip back on the Jedi robes for Mace Windu.
Is that something that you think might happen?
Is that something you'd like to talk to J.J. about?
Yeah, I'd like to be in a new "Star Wars".
I don't know if it will happen or won't happen.
There's a huge debate about whether they should create a whole bunch of new characters...
...and not deal with the old or there's another school of thought...
...where it's easier to bring people into the new "Star Wars" fold...
...by introducing, reintroducing some of the older characters and bringing them in.
I don't know.
I'd love to be a part of it.
If I'm not, I'll still go see it.
But it would be great to be something in it, yeah.